pour cette première page d'été nous
sommes avec chantal gomez styliste
modiste elle incarne à la perfection
c'est art de vivre à la française en
sublimant les chapeaux des femmes
reportage philippe roy vincent régnier
sous nos yeux défilent des modèles de
chapeaux des créations très élaborés et
tour 10 ans vertigineuse pour nos
chantal gomez à feuilleter les pages de
son album donc là ses achats pour
particulier a été fait pour un créateur
japonais
tu fais des robes sans couture j'ai pris
le parti de suivre son sa façon de
travailler et de travailler à chapeau
sans couture c'est à dire ça chapeau qui
drapés amidonné et ensuite qui éteint
avec du safran du clan cnar qu'après un
petit peu de couleurs pour le bleu mais
qui est complètement inhabituelles
chantal gomez est la plus parisienne des
jocondienne cette styliste modiste à
travailler pour la haute couture et pour
le prêt-à-porter une période d'intense
activité 250 modèles de chapeau
chaque année que faites-vous mien je
prends des photos de mes chapeaux pour
mettre sur mon site en ligne et sur une
plateforme de vente ni parce que déjà un
chapeau au cht is on va donc ça me fait
une crasse aussi ça me permet de voir
l'ensemble de ce que j'ai fait après ces
années de tumulte la modiste afa repli
stratégique à joué-lès-tours cette pause
sera de courte durée
elle ressent la brûlure de se remettre à
6 8 6
le feutre à la plage et les rigides
donc il que la vapeur qui va permettre
de le ramollir suffisamment pour le
travailler ou sinon il est impossible à
travailler là jubile jaune d'où le terme
bichonner et on bichonne quelqu'un donc
là je suis dans la salle de coupe c'est
là où j'ai disposé mes tissus comme une
palette de couleurs ce qui me permet de
prendre des tissus de les essayer
d'essayer des assortiments des
superpositions de façon à voir comment
je laime à plus manipuler ce que je vais
en faire
ça va être du drapé si ça va être
recouvrir une forme donc je vais pouvoir
voir un peu comment le tissu se comporte
de façon à pouvoir le travail et par la
suite une fois ma forme préparer comme
on vient de le voir tout à l'heure j'ai
travaillé la garniture l'assemblage
c'est à dire que un chapeau comme ça est
fait en deux parties la calotte et la
passe donc ça nous permet de de combiner
que vous avez vu les formes en feutre
des canotiers avec des bords larges avec
des petits bords de créer à l'infini
qui plus est comme je vais travailler le
feu tout j'ai pouvoir rajouter à la main
des petits détails qui ne sont pas dans
la forme
donc je peux interprété de différentes
façons la forme voire l'inscrit t comme
j'ai là où c'est simple calotte qui m'a
servi de de base et ensuite tout le
reste est scrutée ce qui fait que ça
fait déjà polémique
des chapeaux de ré des modèles uniques
paiement et sur monsieur
chantal gomez merci de nous recevoir
qu'est-ce que vous avez choisi brands
pour nous alors il y à déjà ce modèle là
donc que j'avais créé pour un shooting
photo pour les miss cure vit en région
centre et donc j'avais l'idée de quelque
chose de très aérien pour les mettre en
valeur avec une étole assorti breton qui
fait des effets de transparence sur la
peau là des petites plumes donc c'est
quelque chose de très aérien on n'avait
pas donné son nom
imprévu imprévus oui ensuite il ya celui
ci que j'avais fait pour un salon agora
donc c'est elle et les voitures
anciennes dont qui s'appelle plaisir est
là on voit le travail de transparence la
composition florale le mélange de pub le
jeu de transparence avec de la dentelle
et un drap et organza tulle
quand est-ce que vous avez compris que
le modèle et abouti et que vous pouvez
pas aller plus loin
quand j'ai de l'émotion c'est à dire que
un chapeau aller très vite comme ils
paient l'eau méticuleux et quand je sens
une émotion c'est qu'il est prêt merci
son talent gomez merci à vous d'être
venu le prochain rendez vous c'est avec
une créatrice de poupées devenu peintre